we all have that one friend we just  can't take anywhere with us without a  little explanation and a whole lot of  embarrassment nobody expected what would  happen when the scp foundation  cross-tested scp-682 the hard-to-destroy  reptile with scp-082  a giant aggressive humanoid called  ferdinand the cannibal when they  presented ferdinand with a tissue sample  of 682 he said oh splendid my friend  lives when he entered the containment  chamber 682 immediately attempted to  flee from him despite fernand claiming  they were friends who went way back and  in fact 682 had once been his loyal  steed after extended fighting ferdinand  began to ride 682 and experience the  reptile found supremely humiliating once  zero a2 left the giant was delighted and  as scp-682 said something about him that  we can't repeat if we want to keep  monetization on this video